player because rook h6 and queen g8 will  be just made in two  so black had to play rook h4 which is  already very sad because uh  obviously you don't want to be trading  pieces but it even loses by force i  guess because rook f1 attacks the bishop  and now we take on h4 we give a check  from c8 and we just pick up a full  bishop for  not very much  exactly so this is then also mostly it's  the complete disaster today for croatia  who ends up losing three and a half half  in a in a match where she where they  were basically much  much favored  uh exactly  and this brings us to the last game that  we have been following yeah and it's  still in progress the the game of  vaisali  but i guess we don't like it might it  might go on for  this might go forever yeah yeah  i think this is  supposed to be a draw right this is a  very very classical fnh now  where the only way to continue playing  for a win is to actually give up the  pawn on h3 get the king to f2 play f2 f3  sorry 4